and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalists podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua fields Milburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists welcome to episode 160 today
we're going to talk about re-evaluating
our lives so we can make the changes
that we need to make we're gonna talk
about changes Ryan I'm going through
changes man that's like Freddie Mercury
is doing a cover of the song is that
Black Sabbath or is that Ozzy Sean its
Ozzy okay let's go ahead and dive into
we're talking about changes today and
our first question is from Amanda in
Toronto it's a situation having with a
friend of mine and recently I kind of
realized our relationship our friendship
has hottests like a shift in the
friendship and we have always been very
close we've known each other from work
and we've only known each other for
maybe three years but we have been very
good friends and my friend and I we
usually talk a lot on the phone and
that's a big part of our relationship
like multiple times a day and recently I
kind of just want to concentrate on
myself I've changed a lot in the past
few years and minimalism and like
focusing on like a simple life is so
important to me which kind of lake
doesn't work if you're going to be
spending so many hours like chatting on
the phone each night and so I found it
really hard to kind of tell my friend I
need space all of a sudden when I
realized like this relationship was kind
of interfering with that because my
friend wants to talk so many times on
the phone every day about nothing and
then doesn't really want to get together
or have a relationship outside of that
so now that I've told my friend a few
times like basically that I need space
she feels threatened and like
everything's over which isn't what I'm
trying to do but at the same time it's
pushing me away and I think she feels
hurt and so I guess like we're not on
the same page and I don't know what to
do I think the first thing Ryan that we
should talk to Amanda about here is that
she talks about she wants to simple life
has become this main focus of hers but I
think living a simple life shouldn't be
the goal or the focus that's like if you
want to build a house but your focus is
having a really nice tool belt and I and
you're focused on the tool belt if I
have all the right tools
situated appropriately in this tool belt
I need to upgrade my hammer and what
about this tape measure I need a better
tape measure it's important to have the
right tools and in simple living or
minimalism is a tool one it's an
important tool for improving the
relationships and what she's talking
about here because I think I'm an that
originally called in for our break ups
episode this is a interesting kind of
breakup it's it's like a distancing or a
breakup with a a close friend in a way
and and you and I have had a
relationship for one she said her and
this friend have always been close but
in the very next sentence she said we've
only known each other for three years
hmm and so you can get close to someone
afternoon for three years but right but
I would just I would reposition the way
that you're saying that because you
haven't always been close you've known
this person for three years we've always
been close for the last three years and
you've probably gotten closer you
develop this this relationship but with
developing that relationship
unfortunately there were some
expectations that were poorly set at the
beginning this happens all the time no
especially happens used to happen with
me and intimate relationships in fact
the opposite happens with me now the
reason one of the reasons that Bex and I
have such a great relationship is we did
a really good job setting expectations
early on but with many relationships we
we fall on this we we fall in love or
really we fall in like we fall in lust
there's great chemistry at the beginning
there's a newness and a relationship and
the same can certainly go for a
friendship
and things start off where we overcommit
we over commit ourselves we over commit
to the relationship we over commit to
activities in this case Amanda and her
friend they're over committing to
talking on the phone now amanda was also
being a little bit dismissive of her
friend when she said my friend likes to
talk about nothing mmm
well that's it's certainly not nothing
to your friend and you gotta have a
little compassion for this person there
because clearly they want to talk about
these things maybe it's venting for them
and they feel like nothing to you but it
is not nothing to them it is something
to them now you went to your friend
Amanda and you said hey I need some
space that's probably not how I would
handle this because I understand why she
would feel threatened or she would feel
even if she doesn't feel threatened she
would feel discouraged if you came to me
Ryan you're like Josh I really need some
space in my space from you
I'd be like that what are you talking
about like well cuz it doesn't it that
isn't a it's not concrete yeah it's not
concrete and it's not a very loving way
to tell someone that you need more time
by yourself when you say any more space
right right you're you're you're
actually putting it on the other person
you're putting a void out there you're
saying I need a space what do you need
that space for I think it's better to
yeah to articulate that now for you it
might be hey I need I need more time for
myself because I'm an introvert and
takes that time to to recharge or you
know what I really need to reconnect
with my creativity my creativity has
been suffering because I've been
spending too many hours doing blank or
for you I think this is the the maybe
the more likely example for you amanda
is you're gonna have to reset some
expectations hey this relationship
started off we started speaking on the
phone two or three hours a night I
realized I'm not really a phone person
and this isn't speaking of the phone
just isn't for me I know with backs and
I set that expectation early on or as I
hey I'm not a phone person we're not
gonna be talking on the phone is that
okay with you
and our early I remember our very first
date she asked me she like sent this lit
this list of like some potential things
that we could do is it was on my
birthday
and one of the things was like horseback
riding I'm like you're welcome to go
horseback riding on my birthday I won't
be there for it and the thing was just
like setting the expectations is being
radically honest about it but in a way
that isn't offensive that is not
dismissive it's understanding of what
their needs are what their preferences
are what they like but it's also letting
them know what your preferences are in a
kind caring compassionate way absolutely
yeah I think with Amanda I mean if I was
her I'd be asking myself how good of a
friend of mine and I might say Amanda is
or is not a good friend but that's where
I would start and what does it mean to
be a good friend it means to be
supportive it means to well so being
supportive though there's a lot of ways
to be supportive right I mean supporting
the other person's expectations
supporting them if they have certain
goals are trying to reach supporting
them taking actions I mean there's a lot
of different levels of support there how
much do you be a good friend well I
think as long as those expectations
don't in pinned on or trample your your
life right yeah as we have to keep that
in mind as well because right now what
was she saying is this friend has an
unrealistic expectation of our
relationship but guess what Amanda you
created that expectation and that isn't
you accidentally were a bad friend and
doing that you set some some poor
expectations now here's the thing it's
always great to experiment with
different things I know here's a work
example for us but I think it'll
translate to this Ryan
we've been we've been doing a whole
bunch of different things with YouTube
just experimenting with quickie videos
living room conversations full editions
of the podcast behind the scenes live
lecture election coverage we did one of
those today and so like we do all these
things on our YouTube channel just as
experiments knowing though we set the
expectation early on that hey we're
gonna pull this up back from some of
this we're gonna learn some lessons from
this and here's the good news though
Amanda you've learned a lesson you're
not really a phone person oh okay and
that's okay
and it's okay to present that forward
now in terms of supporting someone how
can you support someone you can listen I
think it's one of the best things we
could do you Ella just got by her first
report card ever
and she it was great except she is not a
active listener I'm so true I think it's
true for many five-year-olds but I think
it's especially true with Ella and I'll
tell you what I I suffer from that as
well although I do a really good job now
I do a better job than most people it's
just like I'm really bad with names
mmm but because I'm really bad with
names I've gotten really good with names
yeah because I realized it is a fault of
mine but it's also something I can make
up for right and so when we go
downstairs to the parking garage here
you and I are maybe two of the only
people in the entire building here the
six storey building who know Jose and we
know ID we and we know Carlos and when
we know I Alston downstairs and an
errand and and Andrew and like we know
the people who are working in the
building and it's not because I'm good
with names no it's good because I made a
concerted effort to go out of my way to
be kind to these people
I listened yeah and well I mean
everything that you're talking about
this this is what it takes to be a good
friend and I know we're not friends with
everyone in the building but taking
initiative like that I think that there
are things like that that really help
help one to be a very good friend and
the reason why I think Amanda should
start at asking herself like how good of
a friend am i it's because if I'm gonna
put it I'm gonna put it on me because I
don't want to talk about Amanda and her
friend so if I'm a man I'm looking in
the mirror and I'm saying hey hey Ryan
um how have you have you treated this
person how could have a friend of you
been with this person if I can look in
the mirror and say dude you've really
gone out of your way to support the
preferences you've gone out of their way
to be a good friend to add value to
their lives to to contribute towards
that us box then at that point I can
look at the that other person and feel
totally comfortable asking them whatever
I want now I think that now when Amanda
said to her I need my space you might
want to just reframe it a little bit I
know with with tough conversations I
have and I talk we talk about this all
the time it's the I versus you you're an
amazing friend you're awesome
I have
problem because I need I need to have
more time in my evenings for myself
because I'm an introvert just simply
explaining putting it on yourself and
explaining why why you need that time
that is gonna help but come across a lot
better than just looking at someone and
saying I need space um it's funny
because that is actually using the I
versus you like that's that is a
statement that sounds like that but it's
still it still is projected had the
other person open it was presenting a
negative as opposed to telling her what
she needs space for what is the
affirmative hey I'd really I really need
to take time to focus on blank don't
tell them what you don't want tell them
what you do want not just for your
relationship that's important but for
yourself so that they can better support
you as well yeah and I think setting
those expectations to like that is part
of being a good friend like Josh I would
never want you to just commit to me it's
a yes to everything that I asked you to
do just because you want to say yes I
know you wouldn't do that but let's say
you were that type of person where you
just people please or I want to say yes
to everything if you didn't set proper
expectations with me or in fact you were
you were causing discomfort or harm to
yourself because of not setting those
expectations like that's to me that's
actually not being a good friend that's
just that's just going with the flow and
I want friends who just go with the flow
personally yeah and since we're talking
about about changes here I think one of
the things to note is sometimes
relationships change over time yeah the
person who was your best friend in
elementary school likely isn't your best
friend right now and the same is true
the people who were good friends when we
worked in the corporate world in our in
our 20s they're not necessarily good
friends now that they might have been
secondary relationships for us that are
now tertiary or non-existent
relationships now relationships change
over time and sometimes you can graduate
from a relationship and you can
appreciate it for what it was I'm not
telling you Amanda to to walk away from
this relationship but always know that
that is an option walking away and
change having the relationship change
now keep in mind people don't hate
change
they hate being changed there are plenty
of changes that we would all accept
[ __ ]
right now right like if Ron I said hey
Ron I changed your bank account there's
now an extra million dollars in it you
don't even have 1 million right yeah at
least $15 dollars 1 million and $15 in
there great sure and and you'd be like
wow I love that change yeah we don't
hate change we hate being change now if
you had a million dollars in there I'm
like hey Ryan I took a million dollars
on your bank account like I don't want
to be changed and the same is true
obviously that's a parodic exaggerated
example but I think it illustrates what
what we go through people don't want to
be dragged to where you are they would
much rather go there willingly on their
own or that lot like for you to meet in
the middle with them in fact Ryan our
relationship has changed over the years
you and I have known each other since
fifth grade and it's the bond over you
know cheese burgers she's anything that
had cheese on it yeah cheese whiz and
now you can't eat cheese I know and I
mean could you imagine him I was like oh
we can't bond over cheese related
products now I need my space I'm gonna
fill that space with cheese no I I think
that I I think that you and I we had you
know particular relationship then and
then the high school was different as me
my brother Jerome your best friend at
the time Pacho and you was like we were
like we look like this Harvard diversity
poster right and and and it was just the
four of us hanging out and so like we
were friends sort of by proxy because we
I hung out with Jerome Jerome who hung
out with patro appacha hung out with you
and then all of us would have got
together and we were friends that way
not necessarily like the best best of
friends then and then right after high
school when you and I started swimming
with different ways I went in the
corporate world you went to go work for
your dad you got married at 18 I didn't
get married until I was 22 so there was
like a friend as I was getting divorced
you were getting married right and there
was this four year period where I don't
know if we had any contact with each
other during that four year period if so
it was rather limited me it was really
some once or twice in that four year
period and so even the best of friends
yeah we're business partners we're great
friends I
we our relationship has changed
dramatically over the last almost 30
years at this point yeah it's changed
several times so even people as close as
us the relationship change in fact I
would argue that our relationship right
now is different from what it was when
we started the minimalists but it's also
probably different from when like 2013
2014 where you were not in 2013 you and
I were both single right yeah
and so we weren't committed to a you
know we were business partners but we
didn't have bed partners at the time
right and so like we were just single
guys we lived it together at one point
and like 2012 20 other pretty much every
day right yeah and so that relationship
was different and now amanda has this
co-worker who she probably sees nearly
every day right but this relationship
will change over time maybe not
immediately but it's almost guaranteed
the only thing that is almost guaranteed
is that some sort of change will happen
you get to determine whether that
changes for the better and better for
you for the relationship or if you're
just gonna drag the relationship through
because you want it to be the same way
forever yeah I mean I think with Amanda
and her changing this relationship that
she's asking us for advice on first and
foremost she has to be a good friend
after she's done that then she can go to
her friend and say hey like here are the
expectations that that I need your help
with this isn't these aren't you know
black and white expectations but here
are some things I'd like to discuss with
you to see how we can maybe uh you know
accommodate what my needs a little bit
more that doesn't mean that she has to
stop talking on the phone or talk on the
phone for two hours I mean she could
simply say hey look because she
mentioned on that on the voicemail too
that like her friend doesn't meet in
person a lot so she could say to her
friend like hey look I really enjoy our
conversations together and and and you
know we've had just these hours and
hours of conversations in fact every day
you know it's a couple hours you know I
I you know a I am finding it hard to
devote that much time and it's it's
really you know it's really important to
me that we have time together but for me
to give you two hours every single day
on the phone that that is not
it's just not something that I can do
it's not sustainable and then the other
thing too is if she wants to meet in
person more she could totally throw out
the idea hey you know let's let's at
least meet up once a week what I'm
really getting at here build on that
that actually builds up anticipation for
the yeah relationship to like my friend
Adam I'm gonna call him back today he
sent me it's acts like we've been trying
to connect the last two weeks it's just
every time I call him he's not available
every time he calls me I'm recording a
podcast or something and and we're gonna
try to reconnect today but like it
builds anticipation gives me things to
think about so we're not talking about
nothing we're talking about something
yeah and you know what to expect so
really what I'm getting out with Amanda
here is find a compromise with your
friend so it doesn't have to be we're
only gonna meet in person we're not
gonna talk on the phone anymore and it
doesn't also mean that Amanda's gonna
give up all her preferences and just
continue this relationship to talk on
the phone for two hours a day so yes you
can schedule calls you can schedule you
know meeting in person but Amanda as
long as you're being a good friend and
as long as you are you know using that I
versus you when you're trying to express
your feelings and your needs when you
again that I versus you is anytime you
say the word you it's something positive
anytime you say something negative
that's when you put it on yourself I am
an introvert I need more time for myself
you're such an awesome friend that I
know you're gonna help me find that time
for myself right so as long as you're
doing that then Amanda you're doing
everything you can and I bet you I just
bet you if you're that close for the
last three years that your friend is
going to help you find a compromise I
like that word compromise Ryan because
you do want to find the compromise the
middle ground that works for both of you
without sacrificing your values
absolutely and keep that because right
now what's happening is you were
sacrificing your values one of those
values is how you use your most precious
resource your time and Amanda I'd love
to send you a copy of our book it's
called everything that remains it's my
favorite thing that we've ever written I
got a copy if you're watching on YouTube
you can see it right here I'll hold that
up this is the camera Jordan no oh this
one all right all right so anyway it's
everything that remains it's the story
of Ryan and I making a whole lot of
chain
in our life we we were the suit-and-tie
corporate guys throughout our 20s we
grew up really poor so we change from
being really poor we focus on the wrong
thing it was putting money first and and
and really only money was the pursuit
for a while a status achievement I guess
where were the other pursuits it but the
proxy was for that was money and there
was a couple chapters in there about
about changes habit change was that was
a big one that was in Chapter number
eight and then Ryan image in the US box
there's an entire chapter in there about
the S box and changing relationships an
important concept I feel like to
understand when when dealing with
relationships so Sean if you could reach
out to Amanda and send her an audio book
version of everything that remains if
you like our podcast you'll love the
audio book version of everything that
remains or if you want the book book or
the e-book we're happy to send those to
you as well and for the rest of you all
we'd love to hear what you have to say
so if you have a comment or tip about
changes including advice for our caller
today leave us a voicemail for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine you
can also email a voice memo to podcast
at the minimalists comm will air our
favorite comments and tips on a future
episode and stay tuned to the end of
this episode for this week's listener
comments and tips Ryan what time is it
you know what time it is it it's time
for our lightning round where we answer
questions from social media yes indeed
we're on Twitter Facebook and Instagram
at the minimalists during the lightning
round this is where Ryan and I each do
our best to answer every question with
just a short shareable lesson 140
character response we also put the text
to these minimal Maxim's in the show
notes so you can copy and share our pith
the answers on social media if you'd
like and now you can find all of our
quotes in one place thanks to our good
friend Jessica Lynn Williams you can
head on over to minimal Maxim's calm
alrighty
our first lightning round question is
from Alicia Alicia writes in I've
changed to a job that makes me a lot
happier but a lot less pay my family has
had to make changes because of it what
are some changes one can make to make a
change like this more sustainable it's a
lot of change
put that change in a jar well here's
I'll give you the pithy answer and then
we'll talk about it a little bit because
this is the
biggest change I had to make in my own
life and I talked about it in everything
that remains so my pithy answer is debt
free is the new pay ray amen and that's
the one thing to think about like if you
have all of these debts if you have
student loan debt if you have car debt
you know you got this car payment every
month you're paying for this oversize
house maybe it's a mortgage maybe it's
just a luxury condo or whatever you're
paying a big payment over there maybe
you're paying for the credit card debt
that you have or you're paying for you
know the the all these other bills that
we have right debt payments yes they're
just debt payments but debt free is the
new pay raise because if you get rid of
that debt you've automatically given
yourself a pay raise so if you don't owe
anybody anything then you give yourself
the freedom to do anything yeah
dude his tweet that to Sean yeah it's
funny cuz like I don't get it as often
but I used to get it a lot when we first
started the minimalist people would be
like oh well it's easy for you because
you know you walked away from the
corporate world and you've obviously had
you know thousands and thousands of
dollars saved up and you know you're
single and you know it's all these like
these assumptions excuses yeah excuses
and ultimately I would just say to those
people like no no it's easy for me
because I spend less money than what I
make and it's not it's not about having
thousands and thousands of dollars saved
up certainly it's it's it's it is a
great idea to have a safety net and to
save for retirement I'm not trying to
say that those things aren't important
but what I'm saying is is ultimately if
you want to have the freedom if you want
to be financially secure you have got to
start spending less money than what you
make today it's okay to sacrifice your
comfort as long as you're not
sacrificing your values yes and I think
that's one of the things we were
spending money all these like creature
comforts and and we're actually stepping
all over our values and doing things
that don't align with the person we want
to become and by the way Bravo to Alisha
here for stepping that direction in yeah
becoming the person she wants to be even
if it means making a little bit less
money or a lot less money in the process
yeah congratulations
lesions Alicia my my short answer is
this if we put money first a meaningful
life becomes the opportunity cost so
what I mean by that for for Alicia is
sometimes we might take this pay
decrease so we can live a more
meaningful life and then once we take
that pay decrease we start to feel the
the pains or the discomfort not pain but
maybe discomfort of those those those
comforts that maybe we have to give up
yeah
but the thing is is to to really feel
good about the decision that Alicia's
made she has to remind herself how she
gave up that you know piece of her
salary she here at the Comfort yeah so
she could live a more meaningful life a
comfortable life is not a meaningful
life here's how I look at it man like
when I so I don't know I made 150 175
thousand bucks that year that last year
I left the corporate world right did not
have thousands of dollars saved up had
nothing to show for the salary that I
was making for all those years but what
I'll say though is that when the next
year when I made like twenty seven
thousand bucks twenty eight thousand
bucks I forget how much it was I
legitimately kind of had this
conversation with myself like man like I
made so much less money this year and
I've never been happier and like I have
never I traveled more that year that I
never traveled thanks to readers letting
us stay on their floor and you know a
sleeping in our car I mean it wasn't
like we spent you know tens of thousands
of dollars to go on that book tour but
but I would sit there and I sat there
and I remember asking myself like okay I
made a hundred and the call 150 thousand
dollars less or one hundred twenty-five
thousand dollars less than the previous
year would I pay someone a hundred and
if I had the money mm-hmm if I if I
could afford it when I pay someone a
hundred twenty-five thousand dollars to
relive that year and I absolutely would
have and that's that's when it comes
down to so Alicia if you ever start to
feel the pain you've got to ask yourself
like
and when I say the pain the pain of
getting rid of those comforts you got to
ask yourself and say okay if I'm if I'm
making $10,000 less a year you gotta ask
yourself what I spend what I pay someone
$10,000 if it would alleviate the stress
of making that extra $10,000 if it would
allow me to live a more meaningful life
with my family the answer is usually
going to be yes yeah if the answer is no
then yeah do something do something
different you know minimalist isn't
about deprivation it's not about just
living with as little as possible it's
about living intentionally yeah and
asking yourselves questions like that
are gonna help you live more intentional
Alicia I'd love to send you a copy of
our book essential it's an essay
collection of 150 essays twelve
different chapters about twelve areas of
intentional living and there's an entire
chapter in here about finances including
the plan that you and I went through to
make sure we got out of debt and more
importantly stay at all of debt once we
got there that's that's the like the
important next step but also investing
in your future as well even on a smaller
or much smaller income so I hope you
enjoyed that copy of a Central Sean if
you could reach out to her give her the
audio book the book book or the ebook
whichever she'd like PS Ryan we have one
more question all right O'Rourke it asks
I'd like a deeper dive into the impact
of involving others in your lives wives
girlfriends family so Ron what you do
with your wives and girlfriends know
about each other and your documentary
minimalism it appeared as if you were
and you were on a singular journey what
kind of word for that documentary maybe
yeah which is easier to direct what
changes when you add partners so if
you'd like to hear our answer to that
question we'll talk about we'll talk
about since our lives have changed
considerably we both have we don't have
partners now we also have employees
that's something else to think about
right we have a whole team of people we
work with this kind of partners too in a
way
yeah yeah they're partners they're part
of this team and the people in my life
are often just part of of a team so you
like if you like to hear our answer to
that question while the whole
conversation about it you can listen to
this week's PostScript episode over at
the minimalist private podcast available
exclusively to our patreon supporters so
if you want to
poor our show and keep this podcast a
hundred percent advertisement free that
head on over to the minimalists comm
slash support in addition to our weekly
PostScript episodes the minimalist
private podcast feed includes our ask
the minimalist anything episodes
unreleased recordings of our live events
and the entire back catalog of past
private episodes once you become a
supporter you'll receive a personal link
to our private podcast feeds to the
plays in your normal podcast player
whatever you use in to listen to this
podcast right now you can find all the
details and all the good stuff over at
the minimalists comm slash support and
here is a snippet from this week's
PostScript episode even with a partner
it's a singular journey because change
starts with yourself yeah any change
that you want to implement you know be
the change that you want to see in the
world you write the blog that you want
the blog in the world like it all sort
of starts with yourself and then of
course it's a it's a ripple effect
alright so now it's time for our added
value portion in the show this is where
we each talk about something that has
added value to our lives
recently Ryan just this past weekend Bex
and I went to go see a movie and it was
one of those movies that is so moving
it's probably the most moving movie that
I've ever seen
Wow it's called beautiful boy okay and
it's about it is about a it's sort of
the opposite of our childhood in a way
where it's about a father whose son gets
addicted to drugs both opium and and
meth but all drugs really I mean every
cocaine and weed and and just everything
he's I mean it sounds like my similar
upbringing for me but okay right well
the thing is the dad he he lives like
this perfect sort of middle-class life
oh I see okay and you and I were didn't
live these perfect middle-class lives
and and it it sort of it did a couple
things one is it Illustrated the sadness
of the
drug epidemics that are going on you and
I are from Dayton Ohio the the overdose
capital of America and so we know about
about that you know we we have a lot of
friends and family who have overdosed we
know people who have died from from
overdoses from opioids and and this was
a little bit different because the
officers also showed the impossibility
of parenting in a way which is both
upsetting and freeing at the same time
yeah because I realized like you oh you
can do everything right it still gets
screwed up yeah or you can do everything
wrong like my parents kind of did
everything wrong and somehow I still
made it out of that oh yeah and and and
I I realized like with Ella like all I
could do is the best that I can do given
the resources and the knowledge the
wisdom that I have but some of it has to
do was a little bit of luck and
ultimately she's going to have to make
her own choices when she becomes of age
and and all I can do is guide her in the
right direction hope that I provided
enough knowledge that she does move in
the right direction but the movie itself
was I mean every time I looked over
Beck's was just tears streaming down her
face and and I mean it was it it it's
such a great film because like man it
stayed with me like I felt it on my
nerve endings this film is amazing it's
in theaters now if you can still find it
I'm sure it'll be on streaming soon it's
called beautiful boy it makes me like
the that makes me feel nervous about
being a parent if Mariah and I ever have
kids I mean we plan on having kids one
day but you know may not ever happen but
the the thought of trying to do
everything to the best of your ability
but there's a certain point where you've
got to relinquish control and you see
that in the film and you see I mean the
hardening of parenting like dealing with
the the relapse and how relapse is part
of recovery and
man it's it's heart-rending and it is so
real and by the way Steve Carell is and
he's the father in there oh my god he
does such a good job okay yeah it's it
is a phenomenal movie beautiful boy all
right what you're adding value to you uh
for those on YouTube I'm showing you
what my added value is right now this
camera Jordan this is this is a book
called micro living my my good friend
Derek dietrichson he just released this
I think on October 30th but what's cool
about this is it's it's basically 40
tiny homes that he kind of does these
very simple dives into but very
meaningful dives that he does so all
these himself he did not so he found he
becomes a tiny house designer and
builder yes and he's got like his own
show on I think he still has his own
show on HGTV but regardless if he
doesn't he
I'm pretty sure he still does but if he
doesn't he had like a reality show where
he would kind of take he would just
build these tiny houses and it was like
from it wasn't like going to the Home
Depot and just buying all the material
whoo it was like you know incorporating
in reusing recycling some materials to
create these beautiful tiny homes what I
really like about this book though is
that it goes into like what the home is
like and then it has like these floor
plans again I'm showing this on YouTube
it has these floor plans where you can
kind of get an idea it's not like exact
blueprints but it does give you
measurements and stuff but there's just
a lot of ingredients here like I look
forward to taking this book and I've got
a couple other tiny house books and
Mariah and I we're gonna eventually
build our own I'm gonna call it a simple
home because I don't know if we're gonna
do like 200 square feet but maybe like
800 square feet something like that yeah
but I can already see some of the
ingredients that I'm going to take out
of this book for for our own recipe but
what I particularly like about this book
is each chapter goes into you know the
person who who has this tiny house why
they have this tiny house and then it's
it's a derrick or he actually goes by
deke deke goes in there and he talks
about what his takeaways are from this
house but my favorite part of each
chapter he's got an in retrospect
action in this this is the most valuable
piece to me in every single chapter how
we failed yeah how we failed or how we
would have done it differently what we
didn't plan for what we would have would
have planned better for if I fail is not
the negative connotation of fail but
like hey this is a failure let's learn
from it yeah we can do better next time
or so other people can do better next
time yes so even if you're even if you
don't ever plan on buying a tiny home or
building a tiny home micro living by
dekeydra's and dietrichson is is it's an
amazing book just very inspiring in just
beautiful illustrations beautiful little
great photos pictures yeah and oh yeah I
guess photos not illustrations and my
good friend Ryan Nicodemus has a chapter
in there oh yes I do Ryan wrote a
chapter in the book when she doesn't get
compensated for well I wanted to help
contribute but uh I I really like the
fact that you go through this book and
there's like look you can build a tiny
house for thirty thousand dollars or
three hundred thousand yes oh yeah they
show you some like are they tiny house
mansions pretty much I mean really
they're so tiny Belaya but it's all the
sort of Kuchar mints and so different
budgets as well Sean can you put a link
to that in the show notes for us alright
let's move on the right here right now
so where we talk about what's going on
in the lives of the minimalists a great
new essay on our website I say great
because I wrote it it's called a more
complete I realize Ryan that but there's
there's often this like alright and
we'll put a link to this essay in the
show notes as well you can always find
new writings just over at the
minimalists comm but on my walk here to
the studio and I walk here several days
a week whenever I walk here there are if
I want take this one particular path
there's like half a dozen to a dozen
different art galleries on these couple
side streets and they have like really
great artwork there right and every time
I walk past like my first inclination is
like Oh wouldn't that look great in
Ella's room or all that we look really
good in our dining room yeah maybe that
would be perfect in our bedroom or
whatever like this painting this
photograph this frame whatever it might
be that would be perfect it would make
my living room more complete I'm like
wait a minute there's no such thing I
mean even grammatically there's no such
thing as more complete right something
is complete it it literally can't be
more complete that's like saying
something is very unique it's either
unique or it's not it can't be more
unique than something and so I would
have realized is that quite often there
are these things that amplify that
enhance that augment our experience of
life and if that's true then great bring
it into your life but just don't think
that the thing is going to make your
life more complete right you are already
complete without the thing and so I've
got a sa there at the minimalist we'll
put a link to that in the show notes and
speaking of the minimalists com a new
month is here Ryan just a couple days
away from December first wanna play a
game it's funny yeah just yesterday we
were in this thrift shop we were
recording a new video hopefully I don't
know if this video will be out yet by
the time this episode is out but 30 day
minimalism game is right around the
corner just go to the minimalists comm
slash game we've had tens of thousands
of people play the 30 day minimalism
game it's one of the most popular
searches on YouTube with respect to
minimalism it's in the top three
searches I think if you search
minimalism and so we're doing a video
about it as well
about the 30 day minimalism game here's
how it works you partner up with someone
at beginning of the month so find a
friend a family member a co-worker
someone who's willing to let go of some
stuff with you next month and you can do
this any month that's that's the beauty
of this game it starts over every single
month so you find someone who's willing
to let go of some stuff in the beginning
of the month you each decide to get rid
of one item on the first day second day
the month two items third day the month
three items starts off really easy gets
you that momentum you need to keep going
builds that momentum because let's face
it decluttering is kind of boring right
and we found a way to make it a little
bit more fun and less overwhelming you
walk into your house if you're like the
average American household you have 300
thousand things in your home you don't
even know where to start well it doesn't
matter you can start with one thing on
day one two things the next day so
anyone can get rid of one thing anyone
can get rid of two things but by the
middle of month it gets more difficult
because day 15 you have to get rid of 15
items and then you realize I'll crap
tomorrow I got to get rid of 16 items
now the beginning
you bet something you can bet a dollar
or a meal that whatever you want and
whoever goes the longest throughout the
month wins if you both make it to the
end of the month and you've both won
because you've gotten rid of about 500
items and that's a really good story you
can join tens of thousands of other
people who are playing the game they're
sharing their experience they're sharing
their photos as well just use the
hashtag men's game like minimalist mi NS
G AME hashtag men's game in fact Shaun
and the shownotes put a link to the
Instagram hashtag men's game yeah you
can see tens of thousands inspired I
think it's over 70 or 80 thousand photos
that are up there right dude it's funny
it was like three or four months ago
Mariah and I we were like God like we're
looking at her drunk drew I'm like we
could play the men's game so we together
did the men's game we weren't it wasn't
a competition we totally did go through
it and we were able to get rid of about
500 things and impacts and I did it last
year we just got rid of all this stuff
it's super easy if you don't do that no
please don't well but actually do do
that but have your kids participate
don't get rid of anyone else stuff for
them that's called theft speaking of
games today was election day were
actually recording this a little bit
early because Ryan and I have some
travels coming up so we're recording
this a couple weeks before it comes out
and we just did a whole I think 36
minute video on YouTube about election
day now you and I have different
political beliefs we have the same
values but radically different beliefs
and but we had this great conversation
about how even though we have different
beliefs we can get along and we also
came up with the idea of how to get
people more informed and here's the
thing we talked about our differences
and so Shawn if we can put a link to
that we did it was a YouTube live video
that we did but it stays posted so it
was called behind the scenes live the
minimalists on election day and Shawn if
you can put a link to that we just
really talked about how our differences
but how we don't let our differences
trample each other but we also talked
about our other responsibilities outside
of voting
and how important some of these other
responsibilities are in addition to
voting yeah yeah I mean most importantly
how being informed is is really really
important yeah and it's not just with
voting I mean yes being informed will
help you cast the ballot in a little bit
more of a deliberate way but being
informed in general whether it's your
health whether it's your you know your
diet whatever it is even exercise it's
like there's so many different yeah so
many every things we vote on so yeah
being informed is really important all
right if you want a comment on this
episode you can do so over at
youtube.com slash the minimalist just
comment over there also on YouTube right
now we have some quickie episodes we
have living room conversations we do
have one living room conversation every
week and we got some house tours coming
soon my house Ryan's house and maybe
your house if you're listening wait a
minute we might be right behind you
right now with Jordan and a camera
alright and if you want our podcast show
notes in your inbox you always hear me
and Ryan talking to a podcast Sean over
there just sign up for our email list
over at the minimalists comm just type
your email in at the top and we'll send
you the show notes every time a new
episode comes out also any new writings
from the minimalist will show up in your
inbox but of course will never send you
spam or junk or advertisements because
all of those things suck speaking of
email simple Sundays every Sunday we
send you an email in addition to the the
show notes we sin on Tuesdays so new
essays or maybe new videos something
that has to do with simplicity simple
living just simple advice for simple
living new emails every Sunday if you
sign up for the email list Ryan what
else you got for us I got some of these
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners check them out hey guys my
name is Tanya I live in Seattle
Washington I'm originally from Nova
Scotia Canada I just wanted to comment
on your Black Friday podcast that you
did recently growing up in Canada we
didn't have JC Penney and Macy's and we
didn't have the big Black Friday sales
like they do here in the States and it
was always my dream to go to one of
those in 2007 my husband and I moved to
Florida and
I met some friends I was like can we
please do the Black Friday thing it's
been a bit of a weird dream of mine so
we did and it was fun and we had a great
time and we did that for a couple years
when I look at it now it's just so sad
how much money is spent and people are
hurt at these sales and sometimes killed
at these sales and for what we're
running around buying stuff we don't
need and and can't afford and it just
doesn't really make sense since we live
out here on the west coast it's been
really hard to send anything home to my
family it's just really expensive and
since we've lived here we decided not to
send anything for Christmas and not to
exchange gifts and really you know my
dad's older and and so my sister and I
and and our kids are in their teens and
20s and none of us really need anything
so we just didn't see the point since
we've lived here the kids and I go to
the Thanksgiving Day Parade in Seattle
on Black Friday and we go to the parade
and then afterwards what we do is we
hand out lunches to people that are on
the streets the homeless people on the
streets who there are a lot of here in
Seattle it's really sad and we make up
turkey sandwiches and we have an orange
and a bottle of water and like cookies
and stuff and last year we also
collected scarves and gloves and we hand
them out to the homeless people and I
think it's been really great to show my
kids that you know it's important to
give to people that just don't have
things and just are less fortunate than
us so it's been really good so we're
gonna do that again this year and my dad
and my sister last year for Christmas
they actually went to the local police
station to talk to some of the officers
and just find out if there were some
needy families that could use anything
specific and there was one little boy
who all he wanted for Christmas last
year was a Christmas tree and between my
dad and my sister she had a tree they
had extra ornaments and lights and they
packaged it all up really nice and they
took it back to the station and the
officers delivered it to the family and
I guess the little boy was just
absolutely thrilled the other thing my
dad and my nephew did was they had gone
to a hockey game and they won
jerseys from the players and my dad was
all excited my nephew who's 24 said
granddad I think we're giving to people
this year and dad's like you're right so
they packaged up the hockey jerseys they
bought some extra hockey tickets and
bought a gift certificate to a local
restaurant and again they went back to
the police station and the officers
delivered that to a less fortunate
family who otherwise wouldn't have had a
Christmas and it was nice the family is
able to go for dinner into the game and
wear the jersey so that's kind of what
we're trying to do and it's a great
example for our kids and just to show
that giving is you know more important
than receiving hello this is Leah from
Denmark but I'm calling from Austria
where a study design and visual
communication I have a comment about
your last episode about Black Friday
which is a concept that I was always
personally against and I have often
boycotted Black Friday completely but my
views changed as Black Friday gave me
the opportunity to save money on a
product that I'm already using I
subscribe to Adobe Creative Cloud which
is a software bundle that cost a lot of
money especially for students but I
really need it for school so I view this
subscription more as a monthly bill
rather than a consumer good and the
specific software bundle that I use for
school it went on sale for Black Friday
at 20% off and I was bold and I
straightly asked Adobe if they could
change my payments and match this
discounted price and they said yes
straight away so because I had my eyes
open I was able to lower my monthly bill
because this is actually a consumer good
that the company is interested in
pushing so I just wanted to encourage
other people to maybe go through their
bills on Black Friday and really think
just because this payment seems like a
total necessity for me maybe you could
still fall into the category of a
consumer good that the company is then
willing to negotiate about or they might
just put it on sale soon alright y'all
that's it for this episode if you have a
question for the minimalists give us a
call for 0 6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 you can also
email a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm and if you leave here
with just one message today we hope it's
this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listen y'all we'll see you next time
and remember read more get informed and
minimus